make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin okay so here's the thing
empire is one of these stories where i
have to let this play out to see whether
i like it or not issue number zero was
cool it was a cool taster reading issue
number one
it's like uh okay like i'm maybe i can
get on board with this i'm not really
sure yet right it's kind of crazy
because this doesn't feel like it should
be a massive crossover event and this
might be one of those times
when marvel's shifting okay so here's
what marvel does guys let's you guys who
are new here's what marvel does marvel
never reboots anything
marvel doesn't do it for whatever reason
they just say if you want to read
spider-man just start reading now and if
you don't understand what's going on
well that's your problem so but the
reality
is this might be one of those stories
where marvel changes things up
in the landscape in order to make things
easier for characters to be introduced
in the mcu and i'll talk about why that
matters here in a second but at the end
of the last video that we did we
basically revealed how the korean
scrolls had basically united under a
single faction and were traveling to
earth for whatever reason why they were
traveling to the moon and we ended up
finding out that this was to destroy the
last of a race called the kotati which
were the original race that inhabited
the planet hala alongside the cree and
we talked about how the scrolls had
visited the planet hala they had taken
some of the creed they took some of the
kotari they took them to the moon they
said build something we'll be back in a
year
and uh that resulted in the kotari
building a jungle and the cree building
a citadel the scrolls liked the kotari
more than the cree
and so they chose the gotati to join the
skrull empire this led to the cree
getting pissed off they basically killed
the scroll delegation reverse engineered
the technology and then the two groups
have been warring ever since kind of a
mouthful but that's the history of the
creed's world war
in like 20 seconds what seems to have
happened here is that the cree and the
scrolls have kind of abandoned their
animosity towards each other and then
join each other in the singular cause of
destroying the the kotati and so when
the the creed scroll armada showed up
here and then the avengers traveled to
the moon to meet the kotali the kotari
were like yeah man they want to kill us
and they were just kind of relying on
the avengers understanding of the racist
history and just kind of going forward
from there then we ended up finding out
the fantastic four were basically
alongside this creed scroll of armada so
the indication was that they had joined
the group
the reality of this is they're actually
coming back from a mission right they're
coming back from a mission the fantastic
four story oh they basically have a cree
and a scroll and it's
it's it's whatever it is but the idea
behind this and this is one of the
things that i don't like
about franklin richards one of the
things i hate so much about franklin
richards
is that when this happens that franklin
wants to stay and the responsive read is
no you have to go home now there's a
couple reasons for this the first is
because of the fact that remember
franklin richard's powers are fading we
don't really know exactly why
we just know that they are and the idea
is to find out why his powers are fading
why he's losing them and solve that
problem now that question was basically
being answered in fantastic four x-men
but of course because of everything
going on with current events
uh that story was put on hold and
marvel's just kind of trickling out
stories until we get to such a time as
the stories are just being released with
regularity the way that they used to so
i have no idea when that story's
supposed to come out i'm sure i could
find a release date i just haven't
looked it up yet but
the other reason why reed richards
basically tells franklin you have to
leave is because the story calls for it
the reality of this is that franklin's
powers are such that he could just phase
the phase the entire armada out of
existence he's like he could just
teleport them all to the other side of
the universe or just solve the problem
with a wave of his hand and that would
be it franklin richards is more or less
a plot device removing him from this
removes that plot device right that's
the thing i hate about franklin richards
he's a cool character
when he's written and used correctly the
way that jonathan hickman did it most
other writers don't know how to use
franklin richard so they just write him
out of the story they're just like he
just has to go home and just just go
there and hang out there and watch
cartoons or something you know just
that's basically what it ends up being
but regardless where franklin valeria
are more or less sent away
this allows susan storm to use her
abilities to make the ship invisible
and then infiltrate the lead ship from
the the creed scroll armada right now
the funny thing about this
is that what you have here is you
basically have clert now
clert is an old school character when i
say old school i mean he's been around
since the 70s he
is the super scroll and you guys have
probably heard of him but basically he's
a guy who has the powers of the
fantastic four
is more or less what it is right he's
got johnny storm's flame abilities he's
got susan storms invisibility he's got
reed's ability to stretch he can
enhance his strength and take on the
form of of ben grimm he's basically got
all their powers but what you have here
is hopeling at the same time
and that's what's so crazy because
technically hulkling is the child of a
cree and a scroll uh so it makes sense
he would be here but we haven't seen him
for quite some time
and to see him suddenly go from the
young avengers to being the leader of
this pre-scroll armada
in this massive story is kind of wild i
think this is one of those instances
where you're gonna see hulkling
basically brought into the mcu which is
why he's being given such a high profile
because the reality of this is there's
no reason for teddy
to be leading a cree scroll armada
that's heading towards earth no one asks
for this but like we're getting it and i
think it's actually it might actually be
kind of cool but basically what clerk
does is use his abilities to essentially
reveal the ship of the fantastic four
right he reverses the invisibility of
susan storm
now the other part of this is we end up
switching directly over to the avengers
themselves right on the blue area of the
moon the home of the kotari here now the
crazy thing about this is again you know
with with ue or however you want to
pronounce his name
you know he of course is a long-standing
character we talked about him in the
previous video you know that he was
basically saved by thor at a previous
point in time and he's currently leading
the kotati race and again he approaches
the avengers even captain america he
approaches them as
something akin to like a a kindly
individual right somebody there is
something somewhat of a savior but again
tapping into this idea of the mcu style
concepts here we end up having uh
she-hulk who's basically given this sort
of amber based hammer and then alongside
the kotati meditation what
it does is it basically gets rid of the
rage she constantly has going on and it
allows her to channel back into her
classic self right where it was
basically jennifer walters who had all
the powers of she-hulk with a
personality of herself right so she
wasn't infinitely strong at the
incredible hulkis but she could channel
that super strength that screams marvel
cinematic universe to me the average
audience i think would largely reject
the notion
that she's just a female version of hulk
because people want to see something new
they'd want to see something fresh and
new having a jennifer walters who can
hulk out but control herself i think is
an interesting concept right it's a
classic version of her character back
when john byrne was doing the character
is probably the most popular one she had
uh it makes sense to take her back to
her roots so i imagine you're probably
going to see her thrown into the mcu or
announced in the mcu at some point in
time
but you know when you have the cree
warship coming in carol danvers
basically issues a kind of broadcast
right now a lot of this is based on the
fact that remember carol danvers was the
leader of alpha flight that basically
she's not really doing that anymore you
got abigail brand that went back and
took over alpha flight again but carol
danvers is still kind of a space faring
character she's been that way
really since the kelly sued iconic run
and so what she does is issue a
broadcast basically saying like this is
an avengers world right if you come here
and you attack the kotari they're under
our jurisdiction because the moon is
avengers territory now the reality of
this is if you're talking about
longevity
it doesn't belong to the avengers right
like this was this was basically
taken by the cree eons ago right like
the well i guess really about the
scrolls if you want to call it if you
want
you want to go that route but you know
it's not really an avengers moon right i
mean this is this is the property of
somebody else all the avengers are
really doing here is they're planting a
flag in somebody else's backyard and
saying this belongs to us now right like
that's more or less what it is
but the fact is that it is the earth's
moon therefore they say it's under our
jurisdiction and then in turn you have
tony stark who kind of makes a comment
saying hey like if it were me i would
just
attack you guys but then he's met by
reed richards and reed richards you know
with tony basically kind of chiming in
as you know
listening to this conversation is kind
of talking to reid as reid is talking to
uh to hulkling and everybody's trying to
understand what's going on
why is hoachling from the young avengers
now leading this this
free scroll armada which is a huge step
up but what ends up happening is he
basically says like he's united these
two factions because they have been
warring for so long but the truth is
that he just kind of seems to be used
right reed richards almost draws that
conclusion right he says if you have
decree and the scroll who have been
waging war against one another then it
makes sense that this alliance didn't
suddenly come because of hulking he
didn't do anything here right he didn't
bring these two factions together
this alliance came together before him
but what they needed in
order for both the cree and the scroll
race to buy into this alliance was to
have someone who was from both worlds
that could unite these races and that's
where hulkland came into play he's a
combination of both and it makes the
most sense to grab him and bring him in
he's a figurehead here
the other part of this is that from the
perspective of tony stark that's not
true from the perspective of tony stark
hopefully is just being used that's his
whole stance right that that where
hopefully he says he trusts
uh trusts super scroll and he trusts
tanoff implicitly both of which are
individuals who have been shown over the
history of marvel comics to have
nefarious practices
that that tony stark looks at and says
but like they're basically bad guys
super scroll has been an enemy of the
fantastic four and the x-men for i don't
even know how long and so is
not they've been bad guys forever like
if you really believe you're not being
used for them to wipe out the kotati
then i don't know what to tell you that
hulking's just being used here that's
all it really is he's just being used to
achieve a particular purpose and so at
the end of the day iron man
basically makes the first move he
launches the first strike and one of the
coolest things we get here
is ghost rider basically using his power
to charge the quinjet and turn it into a
ghost rider quinjet this looks
amazing i just got this giant gaping maw
it's on fire
it looks awesome it looks so cool
but the funny thing is when the
questions ask you know really by read
when the questions ask hey man like is
there some way we can find diplomacy
here right when reid asks a question to
hulkling can we find diplomacy there's
got to be some way to stop this the
response of hulkling is
no launcher attack like he basically
tells them let's go to war
and it's kind of wild here because it
just seems very uncharacteristic of his
character
and i imagine hopefully fans will
probably be pissed uh i don't really
know how you could be because you know
we don't really know enough to be mad
about it right we don't really know the
whole picture here now the story does
end
and there really is no explanation and
he just is out of character
sure then i guess you could be mad it's
kind of wild you know because with the
fleets making their move and basically
going in to attack the kotati what you
end up getting
is of course the avengers and everybody
looking to protect the kotari one of the
coolest things that you get out of this
is you get black panther's buster armor
black panthers
space armor it's cool right to have
black panther don this suit that allows
him to basically leave the blue area of
the moon
and to travel into space and it makes
perfect sense one of the things that i
think is really overlooked about
t'challa wakanda all that kind of stuff
is that yes they're they're you know yes
they live on earth and for the most part
you don't really see black panther like
exploring the universe outside of you
know either being part of the uh the
multiversal avengers or the universal
kingdom of wakanda whatever
you want to call it but like having him
out in space like this and sort of
elevating him up to that stature is
awesome right we've seen it before but
it's just kind of cool to see again
because most stories involving his
character he's just on earth fighting
some people who are trying to invade
wakanda or fighting alongside the
avengers or something like that but one
of the cool things is you end up having
thor working alongside tony stark and
tony's responses
initiate phase two right where captain
america asks like do we have a plan to
stop these guys right or are we really
hoping
that we can just fist fight in armada
compose of the two oldest and most
powerful races in the universe and
somehow win and the response of iron man
is yes we have a plan
thor chucks his hammer into the air with
an iron man device kind of built around
it and of course it goes flying through
and it basically goes up in kind of an
arc
and then comes back down again and when
it does it basically penetrates through
the gravimetric shield
based around this prime ship and comes
crashing down to where hulkling is and
it's something that i've never really
seen before hulkling lifts up his sword
and blocks it and holds it in
place and that's kind of crazy because
that's something that we haven't really
seen all that often
the problem with this is that the way
this story is being done it almost kind
of falls flat and this should be a
bigger moment right because it's not
something that you see very often we've
seen people catch thor's hammer but like
to actually
block it in that way the other part of
this is that because hulkling isn't a
character that's all that celebrated
really all that great the moments kind
of lost on it but there was no real
build up here for the character of
hulking he's just suddenly blocking the
hammer with a sword and it's like okay
but what happens here and the reason why
this is really a big deal is because
what it did is it allowed iron man to
basically initiate a remote viral
package and what it does
is it shuts down all the ships of the
pre-scroll armada now this is a big
moment
because the entire basis behind why this
was happening at least why it was
that that hulking was involved here was
because from his perspective he was
being told the kotati are a threat to
the universe but from the avengers
stance the kotari are just some peaceful
plant rich right
they're like tree huggers to the to the
to the extreme degree and there was no
reason to ever believe that would be the
case as soon as that ends you end up
having ooey or whatever his name is who
basically says like
thank you like thank you avengers you
finally helped us he dons his battle
armor they begin the flowering and the
whole idea here is to basically
wipe out all flesh-based entities across
the universe to get rid of all forms of
organic life that are not plant-based
uh it's basically m night shyamalan's
the happening is more or less what this
is
you know cui basically takes all these
guys out uh the avengers more or less
they're not of course not
killed but they are subdued and the idea
is like at this point we're now going to
spread the empire like we're going to
spread this across the cosmos and we are
going to eliminate
all organic life across the universe and
take back the entire universe for
ourselves now this is where i say
you gotta kind of let the story play out
because if i'm being honest
i don't really have a whole lot of
interest in seeing a whole bunch of
walking plants conquer the universe
don't really it's not really interesting
to me right just a bunch of like
groots cousins conquering the universe
it's weird
but it could get better and that's the
important thing to understand here it
could get more interesting i don't know
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like now we'll
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you